so before we start the video just a
quick 30 seconds of your time please i
recently got sent a brand new benq
w1800i 4k hdr projector and the company
said they wanted me to review the new
system whilst talking about a movie or
tv show that has had a lot of impact on
me so as a thank you to them i'm going
to be giving my thoughts on it towards
the end of the video whilst also going
over how much i love squid game i used
to have the w2700 from them which has
one of the best projector pictures i've
ever seen and we'll be going over
whether this improves on it or not now
in this video we're going to be
answering all of the big questions you
have on squid game including why illness
created it what happened to the front
man and also why he hun did things like
dyeing his hair and it's beyond just
being fashionable now the first thing
we're going to be going over is why
illam created the tournament though very
little is known about the character we
learn in the series that when he was
growing up he played lots of games as a
kid he's included all of the things that
we see in the show and this also
explains why he's so good at playing
them ile nam's entire life is centered
around games and well gambling even on
his deathbed he still attempts to play a
final one with gion in which he better
whether anyone will help a man passed
out in the freezing cold just as he
loses this he loses his life and
everything is all tied together in such
a way that it makes for an awesome final
scene now firstly i just want to go into
the reason behind why he did it at face
value before diving into what i think
the hidden meaning behind it is we
learned that illness built a vast
fortune for himself and because of this
money was never an object whatever he
wanted to do he could but this also came
with its downsides nothing was out of
his reach any longer there was nothing
else that would prove a challenge to him
and thus everything became rather
pedestrian now this actually reminds me
a lot of an old twilight zone episode
called a nice place to visit due to the
psychological aspects in it that episode
followed a man named rocky who was shot
dead after robbing a pawn shop in the
afterlife he met what appeared to be an
angel and he told him that it was his
job to give rocky whatever his heart
desires initially he believed he was in
heaven because he won every single game
that he played and he was loved and
adored by everyone that he came across
however as the episode went on he
realized he was in hell because
everything was going his way no matter
what rocky very much came to the
conclusion that the rest of eternity
would be miserable because his need to
do better and improve had been
completely stripped away from him this
is very much how i view ilnam and he
tells us that he found some common
ground with his other rich friends who
felt the same way thus they set up squid
game and start to recruit people from
across the world in episode 5 we see
that this has gone back decades and that
over the years thousands upon thousands
have met their deaths for the
entertainment of the vips at one point
it's said that this is very much a form
of gambling for them and we as humans
subject animals such as horses to
partake in games for us much like how
ilnam and ko do now why the twist is so
shocking is because illnam comes across
as one of the nicest people in the show
during the marbles game i'm pretty sure
everyone was upset when he apparently
died i'm not gonna lie it made me hate
gihan for a bit i think what illness and
the vips do to ease their conscience is
that they make the majority of the games
something that the contestants have to
agree to everyone signs a waiver before
entering the competition and they are
given options to forfeit and leave with
their lives should they wish to i think
what's likely the case is that they've
done the games enough times now to know
that many will want to quit after the
first one but that the prize money will
always bring them back these are of
course desperate people that we're
dealing with and they're hand selected
by the recruiter likely due to their
appearance and also circumstances thus
to ease the conscience of the vips they
are given the opportunity to quit and
then it's entirely on them if they
decide to come back illness had very
much lived a life of betting and
gambling and we know from the show that
he was diagnosed with a tumor i believe
that before he got greatly ill that the
character wanted to have one more real
big gamble and thus he decided to play
his game from the other side he picked
up number one and interestingly illnam
actually translates to one as well which
is a clue that he was behind it all now
in the game i believe that he finds
something he did not expect to and that
is an heir when we join him at his
deathbed there's no relatives there or
anyone close to him to keep him company
he is truly alone except for gyun and
it's possible that in this game he came
across someone that literally or
figuratively was like a son to him now i
said literally is because there are some
hints in the series that the pair are
actually related in episode three geon
goes to get some milk and he tells a god
that he can't have it and asks for some
chocolate flavor instead ilna makes fun
of him and says that his son used to do
the same and that he'd beat him for it
when they're playing marbles illness
walks through the streets and he comes
across somewhere that resembles his
childhood home interestingly gion also
says that an alleyway resembles where he
lived when he was younger and it is
possible that the pair are related if
that's indeed the case then it would
mean that illness abandoned gion when he
was very young in order to gamble and to
play games this is not dissimilar to
howie mikion who is betting on horses in
debt over his head and also at a point
where his door is taken away from him at
the end of the season he's meant to be
flying out to la in order to meet with
her but instead he ends up heading back
to seemingly stop the games all of these
similarities make me think that illness
wasn't just playing the games in order
to see what they were like but he was
also trying to find a replacement
illness has no heirs or people to pass
his legacy to and thus i believe that he
went through the selection process in
order to see if there was anyone else
worthy to take up the leadership of the
games now this definitely has been seen
in the past and how they've operated in
episode 5 we learned that in ho aka the
front man had actually been a part of
the games and because he's still alive
it's likely that he won them he's also
been drafted into the running of the
games probably because he's now so rich
that he realizes he has more in common
with illness and the like than he does
the typical man that being said i have
no idea how much that amount of money
actually is worth and maybe he still
needs a job anyway this idea of gyun
becoming closer to those in power is
pretty much telegraphed to us at the end
not only does he completely change his
appearance and start dressing smarter
but he also dyes his hair red red
throughout the series is seen as a color
that showcases power and whether it was
the chords given out by the recruiters
or the gods themselves red indicates
someone is part of the system rather
than being a player thus i think the
reason that ilnam created the games is
because he not only wanted a fun time
for him and his friends but he also
wanted someone to take over them in the
finale we learned that the games are
still going on and thus they are likely
looking for other people to either watch
over it or to run it illness has left a
void in the operation that needs to be
filled and i'd absolutely love to see
guillain step into it gina's
demonstrated that he's willing to
abandon his family to take the
tournament down but it might end up
being the key to seeing him becoming the
very thing that he hates now similar to
this ideology the front man was also
willing to cast his family to the side
in order to continue playing the game in
the series we watched as his brother
attempted to find out his connection to
the games and the two eventually came
face to face the front man ended up
shooting his brother and he seemingly
fell to his death after the review part
of the video i'll talk about whether i
think huang junho is alive or not but
this move by inho is very important it
shows that he's now completely detached
from his family and as we know someone
is still running the games in illinois
absence thus i would imagine that he has
now taken up the leadership position as
he was pretty much being put in that
place anyway due to his closeness to
illness the front man describes things
as being a dream and he says to gaeon
that it really wasn't a bad one for him
because of this i believe that he
himself has accepted what he went
through and instead of seeing it in a
negative light like gion does he's now
just viewing it as gambling with people
as the horses anyway before we get in
the final part of the video it's time to
tell you about the w1800i and what i
thought about it like i mentioned at the
start i used to have the w2700
and i absolutely love that projector so
i was happy to get this new one from the
company now where this differs from the
previous model is that it's a smart
projector and it comes with a dongle
that has apps especially built for the
projector such as prime video and more
these aren't just your typical bog
standard versions and just in the same
way your youtube app might look
different on your phone to your tv these
have been designed with projectors in
mind the brand new remote also gives
voice control so you can quickly lock up
shows in a matter of seconds without
having to type things out this leads to
a super easy to use system that's very
straightforward to set up and it means
you can immediately get to watching your
favorite shows and films the new smart
system can also connect to your wi-fi
and it allows screen mirroring from your
phone and ipad the projector is super
simple to set up and you pretty much
just take it out the box plug it in
point it at the wall and turn it on me
and my wife yeah we already had things
set up for an overhead one and it was
just a case of unscrewing that and
putting this new one in which took
roughly about 10 minutes now the
projector itself as far as i'm concerned
provides the best picture i've ever seen
and though my phone isn't really giving
the true detail that it gives off trust
me when i say it looks incredible in
real life due to the 4k hdr picture it
projects really sucks you into whatever
you're watching and it's capable of
projecting a 100 inch image across your
room to really bring that cinema
experience home i thought that the w2700
was as good as the image could get but
this somehow improves on it and makes it
an absolutely incredible picture that
allows you to see films and shows like
never before the projector comes with
state-of-the-art cinema color technology
that provides a million different shades
and when you're watching something like
squid game it really pops from the
screen that show is of course filled
with a number of different colors and
it's got an hdr presentation that makes
it a blast to watch on things like the
w1800i now there are some downsides to
it as well and whereas the last remote
lit up when you press the button on it
this one doesn't so it can make it
difficult to select options when you're
in the dark the sound is also something
that you might need to buy additional
speakers for if you want that true
cinematic experience as it is a bit on
the downside i'm not really a big
audiophile so i didn't mind it that much
but yeah it did feel like it was lacking
slightly i'd say it's pretty much equal
to what you get out most flat screens
these days so you'll know from that
whether you want additional speakers or
not now whilst the dongle is also a nice
addition it's also missing some apps at
the moment but if you've got a fire
stick or something to that effect you
shouldn't really notice too much as you
can of course use that instead overall
though i really really love the
projector and if you're looking to move
in this direction i definitely think
it's the way to go so for the picture
i'm gonna score a 10 out of 10 and
that's purely because i haven't really
seen an image better it's cinema quality
and it perfectly projects 4k uhd discs
and it also streams in really high
quality for sound i'm going to give it a
6 out of 10 and that's just due to the
limitations of the speaker on board it
you probably will want to buy additional
ones if you want the full cinematic
experience at home but it's nothing too
bad now for usability i'm going to give
it a 9 out of 10 and that's because of
the remote
overall though really good projector and
thank you to benq for setting it up for
me to review now finally we're going to
be talking about whether jun ho is still
alive at the end of squid game
throughout the series we watched as he
investigate his brother's whereabouts
and he was shot by him at the end his
body was never found and there are some
hints that he's still alive and that he
managed to escape now the first tease is
that he got shot in a similar position
to his brother the pair both fire at one
another and it's an almost eye for a
nice situation we know that in-house
survives the bullet wound and therefore
it is possible that jungle does too
there is definitely a lot of options for
him to take to get out of there and
personally i believe that he made it now
one of the counter-arguments to this is
that the games are still running and
thus he hasn't brought them down people
have argued that this is because he's
dead but there could be another reason
now the fall likely destroyed all of the
evidence that he had and nursi would
likely have to wait it out another year
until the tournament started up again so
that he could sneak into the facility
under the guise of being a god junhoe
would have to pretend to be dead for a
year in order to accomplish this and it
will allow for him to strike without
anyone finding out so yeah i'm holding
out for you john ho i'm holding out that
hope you better still be alive cause i
want you in season two i've loved
talking about the series and we've still
got a lot of topics to go over including
season two if you've enjoyed it then
please hit the thumbs up and don't
forget to subscribe for videos like this
each and every day we are running a
competition right now and giving away
three copies of the phase 3 mcu box set
on the 30th of october and all you have
to do to be on the chance of winning is
like the video make sure you subscribe
with notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the video we
picked the comments at random at the end
of the month and the winners of the last
one on the screen right now so if that's
you then message me on twitter
heavyspoilers if you want someone else
to watch then make sure you check out
our breakdown of the best theories
surrounding the show which will be
linked on screen right now there's so
many things to talk about in that and
hopefully i see you over there right
after this if not then thank you for
sitting until the end of the video i've
been paul you've been the best and i'll
see on the next one take care peace